just how many drugs was he on like what
are the sort of dosages for those of us
that aren't uh a part of the of the time
I had there was igf-1 CJC iphamerelin uh
mk677 GH Winstrol Deca test so eight
and that's you know just going into the
you know the the questionnaire of trying
to just say this is what I'm doing right
now but I need Next Level and I need to
you know figure this stuff out now he
was trying to figure out how why all of
the GH related stuff he was using was
not working because he does I believe
have a unique genetic predisposition
that makes it harder to produce igf-1 or
with some of the other drugs he was
using that were kind of inhibiting it
but what gives you that sense well
because it's igf was less than 100 which
is reflective of somebody who is
like chronically malnourishing
themselves potentially
um and like uh I don't know chronically
keto dieting potentially fasting way too
much like he's not representative of
somebody who's in uh like a growth State
necessarily what makes you think that
that is something which is uh inherent
to him and not a byproduct of the
lifestyle that he's leading
ah because we're using that much [ __ ]
it's really hard to imagine that you
wouldn't manually be putting your igf-1
way higher like there's like he's a
smart [ __ ] guy even though he dumbs
himself down on podcasts to come across
as more relatable and make it more
understanding for
um the people he's trying to inspire or
whatever because some of the stuff he
would talk about otherwise is
complicated especially when it comes to
you know the like I don't know
biomarkers and endocrine hormones and
what kind of impacts certain foods have
like he very much
dials it down to be as palatable and
comprehensive and uh I don't know like a
palatable for the average person
um but I don't know like just the the
low value was something that he couldn't
even wrap his head around like that's
one of the motivations that he was
seeking uh guidance on essentially like
why am I on all this [ __ ] it's not
working well I suppose that's one of the
framings where you could have gone look
uh I think that there's something
physiologically going on here I've kind
of got myself into this strange feedback
cycle of taking more drugs to fix a
problem which potentially means that it
shuts down production more which makes
more yeah
that wasn't really the nature of the
emails that was a part of the emails but
the majority of the emails was yeah it
was driving the brand and just getting
virality yeah
yeah I just uh yeah it would have been
uh more ethical of him to disclose what
he was going to do with it and then give
the opportunity for whoever he is trying
to contact for guidance to decide from
there
I'm okay with that in the way you're
gonna do it versus not do I want to be
the rocket fuel for this ship that's
going to be stratospheric yeah it's like
obviously you're not the one on camera
doing it but like you're very much
providing guidance and endorsing the
process that he's doing that's the first
time that I've heard that taken I think
it's a really interesting one like that
that's a really interesting ethical
dilemma for somebody to be in like if
you want to synthesize the smallpox
virus so that someone can study it in a
lab or synthesize the smallpox virus so
someone can weaponize it and send it out
into the world
yeah yeah it's not quite the same but
yeah um do you believe that he's now on
a therapeutic dose of 100 milligrams of
test per week
um well it's 120 but even I would if he
doesn't put up blood work regularly
which well you know he has no obligation
to I'm sure people would like it though
so they can know he's uh you know
representing the ancestral lifestyle
well and isn't walking around with a
stressed out liver and kidneys and
[ __ ] up markers and stuff
um I'm sure he is probably doing
something that he believes to be
more therapeutic than blasting his face
off but it is uh
if you're maintaining that physique
whatever you're doing is clearly not
representative of physiologic
replacement like even guys who were
because he's not got smaller yeah like
if you're if you're on 120 milligrams
depending on where your test levels land
it might not be therapeutic replacement
like for context again like I've seen
the guy's blood work and
it's
some of these levels they will sustain
themselves in perpetuity essentially
because of the way the drug is released
into the bloodstream like it's a long
Ester and you are not having any dips
following a diurnal Rhythm through
normal pulsatile secretions which
happens endogenously when you have
natural testicular output of
testosterone like normally you would
have test levels go up in the morning
they would dip kind of like go up and
down up and down and you would not have
a disproportionately high free tea
testosterone that is supporting enhanced
amounts of muscle mass whereas when
you're on exogenous trt even if you have
you're training twice a day or you're
you know getting shitty sleep or you go
out drinking or whatever it is like your
levels stay exactly where you want them
to they don't dip they don't change and
you have a disproportionately high free
tea so even though on paper it might
look like you're in the reference range
like it might not be representative of
that and that's not to say he is or
isn't in the reference range because
he's definitely been
[ __ ] he's deaf he's definitely holding
something that is unsustainable if he
came off everything put it that way yeah
I mean that was the conversation you
originally had with mata's Fitness right
so for people who don't know Matt's this
big Fitness YouTuber who's in really
really great condition and he wanted to
come to you to get uh the most highly
scrutinized
um type of blood work at a Cadence that
you thought was good enough for him to
be able to prove his natural status yeah
and uh the issue that you had or the
concern that you had is if we start to
do these tests a randomized frequency
and your condition begins to change or
the lift that you've got begin to change
or we see some anomalies within the
blood results yeah if there's no
anomalies and if your condition stays
the same we can be pretty reliable at
knowing that right now you are not
taking anything to enhance
it seems like liver King's just getting
linearly bigger and leaner and drier at
the moment yeah I think he's probably
plateaued by now but yeah in your
mid-40s you don't walk around like that
and you don't hold that when you are
working out twice a day
you know have been spread so thin
entrepreneurially having a family to
support et cetera et cetera like you
know again he doesn't have that much
historical
photos anyways to check his progress and
like when things you know picked up
heavily but like he very much kind of
elucidates himself what I think is
representative of Prior liver King where
it's like my cruise dose is this even
though you're coming into uh like this
is me coming to you from square one this
was my cruise dose heavily implying I
have blasted because you would never say
Cruise dose if you're not a guy who
blasts
if it was just HRT you would just say
HRT but it wasn't therapeutic do you
believe because he stays in the well
again I don't want to misconstrue like
0.60 sees a task could very much be
therapeutic like I'm not saying that's
high it very much depends on what
achieves symptom relief what your levels
again like the levels on a piece of
paper are kind of just arbitrary at the
end of the day
it's about what if you had primary
hypogonadism and you needed trt Whatever
Gets you to
symptom relief is probably what you need
even if it some guys need more than what
liver King takes and testosterone dose
but I'm just saying that the context in
which he presents it very much implies
that previous to even the request for
how do I optimize my igf-1 and take you
know why is the GH not doing what I
think it's going to do
there was to build the physique where he
got like there was a blasting involved
so you believe because he he says in uh
his apology that he was natural for 36
years of training twice a day I think
that's seven days a week he kind of yeah
I don't know why he put that in like he
makes it sound like he just started
hormones like right at that time it's
like well then your physique would have
morphed by from then to now and
you know it's just not representative of
that and it was just more so the
verbiage too because again you would you
would never say I cruise if you're if
you've just started HRT you wouldn't
even know what the [ __ ] cruising
blasting is you know it's just very well
maybe you would but it's like you would
never use that verbiage unless it
implies this is my Baseline to try and
hold on to what I have but when I'm
pushing the envelope
it's something else what's happening
people if you enjoyed that then press
here for the full unedited episode and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]